that's not the plan
was gonna say did it spiral out of
control so much that you guys were
publicly so associated with with each
other that it kind of was like a forced
because listen
blue faces girlfriend well you when
y'all came to the studio
baby um it was you could cut the tension
between y'all with a knife yeah no it's
kind of like it's kind of like
she got on the blueface's boyfriend
girlfriend I mean you wouldn't have a
boyfriend obviously
you got on his blueface's girlfriend but
it's like
she kind of like
use that and then when it wasn't usable
she kind of used that and then when it
wasn't usable she kind of like all right
let me
let me let me go this way you know like
I said I'm not gonna fire you are you
hoping she gets the tattoos removed no I
mean I really don't care for me
personally tattoos are a part of time
history you know trials and tribulations
and I feel like I'm a part of her time
his three trials and tribulation so
is there any more business for y'all to
do together
man I'm always interested in business
I'm always open to business but like I
said earlier once you do business
without me it's none of my business and
the relationship aspect of YouTube is
done I mean she has my if she has my
child I'm gonna no no you guys are gonna
have a relationship I just mean in terms
of like you guys being intimate you guys
being you know any sort of uh
are you done clapping Christian Rock's
cheeks at this point in your life
personally
I don't think that
I think that she she might need to be
humbled something might need to occur
for her to
realize okay
all these people all year round because
of who I am today and not who I was
three years ago
and it's just a Harmony experience you
know like it's like I saw I saw Chicago
the club and I was just like damn like
well that was recently yeah like two
days ago
like hey they keep deleting my Ig like
here's 10 grand go sit down like I don't
want to trust him to get miscarriage
trust me I will pay for her to sit down
but
she's into the attention she likes
people walking up to her she likes the
camera she likes the attention so it's
like I can't fight with her on that you
feel me like if you get more of a
feeling of people saying hey hey then
you get off being home and and enjoying
having a home to be at and having you
know your own then I'm not gonna fight
with you on that bro because